[Aplausos]
[Música]
libia es un país con más reservas de
petróleo que eeuu de hecho es el país
con las mayores reservas de crudo de
toda áfrica a pesar de todo esto a duras
penas son capaces de exportarlo de hecho
hasta irán con las sanciones de trump
produce más zumo de dinosaurio que libia
[Música]
y os preguntaréis por qué la respuesta
es muy sencilla habéis oído hablar de
las primaveras árabes pues bien
libia es uno de los países que peor
terminaron con todo este proceso
básicamente si hay una lección que
podemos aprender de libia es que si algo
va mal puede ir aún peor
[Música]
he visto la película 'el dictador' con
sasha baron cohen se trata de una
comedia donde hablan de un tirano que
vive rodeado de lujos mientras oprime a
sus opositores pues bien el modelo en el
que se inspiraron para hacer esta
película no es otro que muamar el gadafi
sin duda alguna uno de los dictadores
más excéntricos de la historia que fue
quien gobernó libia por más de cuatro
décadas para que os hagáis una idea
gadafi era conocido por tener su propio
harén con más de 30 mujeres
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís se trataba de la
llamada guardia amazónica y era algo así
como las guardaespaldas de gadafi de
hecho una de estas guardaespaldas llegó
a morir en el año 1988 interceptando una
bala que iba dirigida contra gadafi y
por qué digo que era su harén personal
pues atentos para formar parte de esta
guardia amazónica tenías que reunir unas
condiciones tenías que ser mujer hacer
un juramento de virginidad llevar
maquillaje y pintauñas
historias de violaciones y abusos hacia
esta guardia amazónica por parte de
gadafi un dictador que por otra parte
siempre se vendió como un auténtico
feminista un hombre que defendía los
derechos de la mujer en el medio oriente
pero las locuras no terminan aquí
gadafi tenía miedo a las alturas y por
eso siempre que iba a un hotel tenía que
hospedarse en el primer piso y nunca
podía subir más de 35 peldaños en una
escalera en otras palabras que si
hiciéramos un ranking de chalados a lo
largo de la historia
gadafi estaría seguramente en el 'top
ten' y algo parecido pasó con la
diplomacia gadafi pasó de ser el enemigo
número uno de eeuu a convertirse en una
de esas dictaduras amigas de la casa
blanca para después terminar de nuevo
como ese hombre al que da gusto odiar y
os preguntaréis ahora que gadafi está
muerto qué tal van las cosas por libia
pues seamos honestos bastante peor para
que os hagáis una idea la situación en
este país es tan caótica que hasta las
petroleras han tenido que terminar
haciendo acuerdos con señores de la
no me creéis pues atentos a esta noticia
el campo de repsol en libia retoma la
actividad tras el acuerdo con los
asaltantes
en este caso repsol es una petrolera
española en el año 2008 durante el
gobierno de gadafi firmaron un acuerdo
con la empresa nacional de petróleo
libia sin embargo durante la guerra
civil distintos señores de la guerra
secuestraron las plantas petroleras así
que tras años de conflictos
repsol ha tenido que hacer un acuerdo
con una tribu es decir las propias
empresas asumen que el estado libio es
una entelequia aquí quien realmente
manda son los señores de la guerra
[Música]
así que la vida
como hemos llegado hasta aquí que está
pasando en libia hoy en día cómo es
posible que una empresa de petróleo
quiere hacer acuerdos con una tribu hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia el
malo de la película en los años 80
gadafi estaba en la lista de súper
villanos favoritos de eeuu al mismo
nivel que el ayatolá jomeiní y gaming o
los comunistas el clásico malo de las
películas de espías y os preguntaréis
por qué pues no os preocupéis y ahora
mismo os lo cuento
[Música]
a principios del siglo 20 libia era una
colonia italiana después de ganar la
independencia pasó a ser una monarquía
pero las cosas cambiaron en el año 1969
año en el templo amar el gadafi llega al
poder
gadafi fue uno de los grandes
representantes del llamado socialismo
árabe un corte ideológico que mezclaba
al laicismo economía centralizada y
culto a la personalidad
[Música]
algo parecido ocurría en los países
vecinos como egipto túnez o siria
gadafi llegó a escribir un libro el
libro verde que se convirtió en algo así
como el cincuenta sombras de grey del
socialismo árabe pero no sólo eso el
dinero del petróleo permitió que gadafi
pudiera apoyar a muchos políticos de
otros países es más varios partidos
socialistas en europa recibieron dinero
libio para sus campañas
sin embargo a diferencia de otros países
como egipto gadafi no era tan amigo de
las nacionalizaciones por supuesto que
nada más llegar al poder
renegoció todos los contratos que había
con las petroleras extranjeras pero en
ningún momento las expulsó gracias a
esto libia pudo tener una industria
petrolera competitiva en otras palabras
que gadafi podía ser muy socialista muy
dictador y muy lo que queráis pero libia
estaba abierto para hacer negocios
repsol dice que la nacionalización del
petróleo libio es poco probable y seamos
honestos la fórmula funcionó muchas
empresas europeas como la italiana eni
la francesa total o la española repsol
continuaron haciendo negocios en línea
el dinero entraba en el país y el
petróleo salía los ciudadanos mejoraron
sus condiciones de vida y es más en
algunos momentos libia llegó a tener el
índice de desarrollo humano más alto de
todo áfrica superando incluso a
sudáfrica entonces donde estaba el
problema porque eeuu le tenía tanta
manía a la fama
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pues no la respuesta tiene muy poco que
ver con el petróleo la respuesta está en
la política exterior
gadafi no se limitó a apoyar a partidos
políticos sino también a grupos
terroristas desde el ide irlandés hasta
el frente de liberación palestina
básicamente en mitad de la guerra fría
gadafi era un aliado de los soviéticos y
todo lo que sirviera para desestabilizar
a occidente se veía con buenos ojos
desde trípoli
sin embargo la gota que colmó la
paciencia de la casa blanca llegó con el
atentado de berlín en el año 1986 unos
terroristas pusieron una bomba en la
discoteca de berlín donde solían ir los
soldados de eeuu así que después de
demostrar que los espías libios habían
estado detrás del atentado el presidente
de los eeuu que por aquel entonces era
ronald reagan tomó cartas en el asunto a
las siete en punto de esta noche las
fuerzas aéreas navales de eeuu lanzaron
una serie de ataques contra los
cuarteles instalaciones terroristas y
activos militares que apoyan las
actividades subversivas de muhamar
gadafi
el propósito del ataque era acabar con
el llamado perro loco de oriente medio
que es como ronald reagan le llamaba a
muamar gadafi pero el dictador
sobrevivió desde entonces la casa blanca
puso a libia en la lista de países que
colaboran con el terrorismo y así es
como las petroleras estadounidenses
tuvieron que abandonar libia
podéis imaginar esto le vino de perlas a
las petroleras europeas empresas como
total repsol y eni que ahora tenían
terreno libre para explotar los campos
libios
[Música]
donde repsol desarrolló uno de los
mayores yacimientos petrolíferos
descubiertos en los últimos años
millones de barriles de crudo esta es la
fuerza del petróleo pero vamos a avanzar
con nuestra historia si recordáis el 11
de septiembre de 2001 eeuu sufre el
mayor ataque terrorista de su historia y
ahí es cuando a la posición de libia
cambia radicalmente
efectivamente gadafi había apoyado a
grupos terroristas pero nunca había
apoyado a los extremistas islámicos
así que osama bin laden era un enemigo
común tanto del 'tío sam' como de muchos
de estos socialistas árabes y así es
como gadafi empezó a colaborar con los
eeuu el primer síntoma de esto fue la
firma de un acuerdo de desarme nuclear
libia se comprometía a destruir todas
sus armas de destrucción masiva el
segundo síntoma fue la ayuda en la lucha
antiterrorista así que de repente en el
año 2006 eeuu sacó a libia de la lista
de países que colaboran con el
terrorismo de repente gadafi pasó de ser
un hijo de va a ser nuestro hijo de y
sin embargo las cosas cambiaron en el
año 2011
la primavera árabe la primavera árabe
empezó en diciembre de 2010 cuando
mohamed buaziz y un vendedor callejero
tunecino se quemó a lo bonzo en una
protesta nunca se imaginaría que algo
así podría despertar semejante
revolución los tunecinos empezaron a
protestar contra su gobierno que también
era una dictadura de socialismo árabe y
estas protestas inspiraron a los países
vecinos de repente todos los países del
norte de áfrica estaban intentando
derrocar a sus respectivos dictadores
y como os podéis imaginar libia no era
la excepción en este caso en 2011 la
guerra civil estalló y curiosamente
gadafi llegó a apoyar las primeras
protestas a fin de cuentas él se
consideraba el líder y guía de la
revolución así que las manifestaciones
eran lo suyo pero como ya sabéis hechos
son amores es muy difícil defender que
eres un revolucionario cuando llevas 40
años en el poder
así que los manifestantes dieron la
espalda al gobierno de gadafi y gadafi
cambió totalmente su retórica
gadafi dice a los medios que mi gente me
ama y morirían por protegerme'
el líder libio se ríe ante la presión
internacional para abandonar el poder
mientras habla con los periodistas en
unos días los opositores ya estaban
controlando bengasi y muchos sectores
del gobierno se rebelaron contra el
propio gadafi los rebeldes continuaron
organizándose pero como os podéis
imaginar el dinero del petróleo había
permitido a gadafi hacerse con un
ejército en condiciones
mucho más allá de esa guardia de las 30
amazonas gadafi tenía armamento moderno
y miles de soldados y todas estas cosas
pues hombre son muy útiles para reprimir
a las protestas así que qué ocurrió
entonces pues que la imagen de gadafi en
el exterior no podía ser peor de repente
pasó de ser nuestro hijo de está a
convertirse de nuevo en el malo de la
película un violador de derechos humanos
y así es como una coalición de la otan
liderada por francia invadió libia en
marzo de 2011
[Música]
en poco tiempo los cazas franceses
dieron la vuelta a las tornas
los bombardeos obligaron a grafía volar
desde la capital de libia trípoli hasta
su ciudad natal sirte y ahí es donde los
rebeldes lo encontraron y lo capturaron
el 20 de octubre de 2011 un vídeo
liberado por los rebeldes mostraba a
gadafi suplicando por su vida horas más
tarde gadafi estaba muerto y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos quien va a
llorar la muerte de un dictador son
siempre buenas noticias verdad pues
esperado un momento
[Música]
en guatemala a guatepeor el cuerpo de
gadafi se paseó por todas las calles de
libia para que el pueblo pudiera
profanar lo agusto pero una vez pasada
la euforia para acabar con el dictador
los rebeldes se miraron unos a otros y
descubrieron que no tenían nada en común
es más que se odiaban unos a otros y
como ya sabéis el poder no admite vacío
sin un gobierno efectivo libia cayó en
manos de distintos grupos y tribus
locales muchos gobiernos occidentales
pensaban que tras el fin de gadafi
podrían seguir haciendo negocios con
quien quiera que le sucediera
craso error
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y de repente los señores de la guerra
intentaban tomar el control de los
grandes pozos de petróleo y todas esas
empresas occidentales tuvieron que
abandonar muchas de sus instalaciones
sin embargo como los líderes de las
tribus no sabían usar la tecnología
petrolífera muchos de estos yacimientos
terminaron sin poderse utilizar y eso
explica que en 2015 la producción del
petróleo cayera en picado sin embargo
pese a todo esto algunos de los
generales europeos que lideraron esta
intervención están bastante contentos
con su trabajo
[Música]
el expresidente de la otan dice que
libia fue una intervención modélica y os
preguntaréis porque el señor rasmussen
está tan contento con el trabajo que
hizo en libia para entender esto
tendremos que entender la diferencia
entre el estilo de guerra estadounidense
y el europeo o más concretamente el
francés como decíamos antes la guerra de
libia fue una guerra liderada por
francia normalmente cuando los
estadounidenses preparan la invasión de
un país mantienen sus tropas durante
años el ejército no solo debe acabar con
un dictador sino que también tiene que
ayudar a la transición democrática este
modelo funciona muy bien en japón y
alemania durante la segunda guerra
mundial aunque parece que tiene algunos
problemas en irak o afganistán
básicamente el ejército estadounidense
se queda en el país que ha invadido para
intentar formar un gobierno de posguerra
y sobre todo neutralizar a los grupos
fieles al dictador depuesto sin embargo
los franceses hacen todo lo contrario en
francia llega un país lo ataca toma los
principales objetivos militares de pone
al dictador y se marcha
fácil y sencillo hemos visto situaciones
parecidas en mali y algo parecido
ocurrió en línea eso explica que si os
fijáis en esta gráfica veréis que la
guerra de libia fue una de las más
baratas de la historia comparada con
afganistán o irak libia fue una
intervención extremadamente efectiva
[Música]
el problema el problema son las secuelas
tras la caída de gadafi surgieron tres
grandes facciones por un lado el
gobierno de trípoli que estaba apoyado
por turquía y qatar por el otro el
gobierno de tobruk apoyado por egipto y
los emiratos árabes y por último el dax
todo este caos sirvió para que el da es
también conocido como el estado islámico
pudiera aprovecharse del caos y
expandirse y aunque en 2014 se formó un
gobierno apoyado por las naciones unidas
a duras penas tenía apoyo real entre la
gente
para que os hagáis una idea se estima
que más de 4.600 personas han muerto
luchando desde el inicio de 2014 las
naciones unidas dicen que casi dos
millones y medio de personas han estado
afectadas por la guerra
eso implica escasez de comida y escasez
de medicinas
la guerra olvidada la crisis se
recrudece en libia pero dónde están las
cámaras en el momento en el que haremos
este vídeo la situación no ha mejorado
el gobierno no puede garantizar la
seguridad en el interior del país ni
siquiera en la costa
y por eso las petroleras han terminado
haciendo acuerdos con los únicos que
tienen cierto poder político y quienes
son estos pues quien va a ser los
señores de la guerra
[Música]
el campo de repsol en libia retoma la
actividad tras el acuerdo con los
saltantes pero ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros si hasta las empresas de
petróleo tienen que hacer acuerdos con
los señores de la guerra podemos decir
que hay oportunidades para que libia
tenga un gobierno democrático veremos
alguna vez como libia tiene una
situación estable para todos habría sido
posible dar una mejor solución a la
crisis de libia y a la dictadura de
gadafi
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones que os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a light y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]